welcome back time is counting down it's
the end of our show and i want to
check in i get to answer questions
stephen b
jammin tweeted at the drewberrymore show
tv
what can you count on each day that
gives you inspiration for the show um
okay you know you know what it's the
crew
and the team it's true
i am a total pisces and i feel
and read people's energy i'm very
intuitive so
i want to make sure everyone who's
working on the show feels good and
settled and then i feel good and settled
okay now let's get a question why i love
you guys let's get a question from our
virtual friends hello virtual friends
floriano
hi how are you
i'm good what about you good do you have
a question
yes i want to know what's your favorite
thing about having a talk show
i mean it's hard to put into words i
know that i felt this
yesterday that i just don't want to get
fired i love this job so much and
when you know you don't want to lose
something you know how much it means to
you
and i know how much this means to me so
i'm in the moment
i'm present i'm here and i'm honored to
be for as long as i get to be
so i hope you had a blast we'll see you
tomorrow baby
have a great rest of your day take this
in with you
you